maybe you keep going this way it's like
can you please communicate with me
you know happens
I'm down to vote for if you are down to
what so I'm down to Eliminator if you
are oh wow I was kind of just like what
but no actually I was like what what
my damn time right now if you don't vote
for her I'm banishing firsthand's like
yeah you better vote with her whoa it's
bad timing but it's especially a bad
timing because she's in our group
these shoes are the worst okay guys you
got this come find me which one are we
going just follow the path just keep
following it look at the map Andy yeah I
am Andy's the one in charge of the
directions had me confident I think we
have to go all the way back the opposite
direction that we came down
I can't believe we are lost
we have probably walked like a mile in
the wrong direction I think we should
have kept going
straight down the road instead of
turning right away yeah
I hate as a leader failing like me am I
going to be murdered because we just
happened to go the wrong way we have to
literally go back to where we started oh
[Music]
what the hell's going on hurry up
15 minutes to go
come on
is it worth five thousand dollars Thomas
running out y'all good
I'm getting ready to go out my friends
are like we're here where are you I'm
like oh I'm on my way I'm in the Uber
and really I'm still drying my hair
I don't like to be rushed
[Music]
we got the big shield on the right
Shield
baby can you hear anything yo I can't
hear you we're digging in the car from
standby
yeah
yeah guys hurry up are you guys at a
graveyard because I don't hear anything
they might be digging for another clue
we got a clue Tom we got a clue we got
another clue cop white flowers what in
the world we found a flower we were
looking on the map right now wow right
there
I would Sprint if I were you guys let's
go come on you got this
[Music]
ow you okay no I'm really not
a graveyard
it's this one guys
so proud of you let's do it
what does that mean right here we have
to go to the Rose let's go we got this
[Music]
Park
I hear the Cavalry approach we're Club
s
there are literally people in the grave
here waiting for you can anybody hear me
anybody anybody
come on
I hear you guys hurry up hustle
they're here they're here yellow and
blue team now have to dig up there two
players right here right here hang on
right here right here five minutes left
flowers flowers there it is that's it
we're digging right now we're digging
right now
start digging start digging get me out
of here
[Music]
I'm a hair stylist from Staten Island no
I'm not active this is the biggest
workout of my entire life that I've ever
lived ever done ever anything this is
the craziest thing I've ever done all
right let's keep doing it Jake hurry up
come on guys come on one of the last
ones and there was only one person who
had the map leading the way
Geraldine
I swear to God and it's annoyed in my
life
digging up a grave
my strong suit and I'm proud
only a few minutes remaining tick tock
tick tock come on guys let me out hey I
need you guys to help pull this thing
off Christian he was like ah it was like
the Incredible Hulk dip crack
he hit me with his shovel
fake I'm good just don't like him
quickly people quickly
[Music]
a player has been rescued five thousand
dollars to the prize bud
[Music]
yeah
guys I think we really killed it these
are gonna be great people to work with I
definitely trust them even Cody our team
worked together so well
foreign
[Music]